entrepôt privatiser comité d'accueil et
clientèle service sur mesure en ce
moment emmaüs or non c'est un peu comme
un club vip un service conciergerie qui
enchaînerait les commandes
c'est surtout les décorations de noël et
puis c'est pour mon groupe les commandes
avec toute la famille donc comme ça ya
qu une seule personne qui vient chercher
ses pratiques
né d'une demi plaisanterie l'idée d'un
brock drive a sérieusement fait son
chemin puisque le monde entier cliquez
collecte pourquoi pas la boutique
solidaire même si tout cela demande
beaucoup de travail et de bonne volonté
qui met les annonces en ligne
moi je fais les photos par exemple il y
en a qui répondent aux persos clients
sur la page facebook ont passé beaucoup
de petites annonces comme ça sur la page
qu'une quarantaine par jour
oui bas depuis le début on a fait au
moins 120 commande vous voulez garder un
petit peu de contacts avec eux notre
clientèle habituelle
et puis pouvoir répondre à certains
besoins plus particulier alors que ce
soit décorations de noël parce que c'est
la période quand même les gens sont un
petit peu prévu en ce moment et c'est un
petit peu un esprit de fête aussi
et puis aussi des produits de première
nécessité on a vendu aussi bien dvd
frigidaire que des tables des chaises
des prix minimes ce qui permet de
dépanner les gens
impossible bien sûr de photographier
l'intégralité des stocks sur la page
facebook mais la boutique solidaire
enseigne volontiers des commandes
spécifiques
les habitués adhère sans compter ou
presque pour ce minimum qu'on puisse
faire
et qui en même temps pour moi c'est pas
mal aussi il faut être gagnants des deux
côtés en fait
et bien je vous remercie pas du coup je
vous laisse les 5 euros pour la caisse
commune
vous avez des petits cadeaux merci
beaucoup
il est peut-être un peu tôt pour parler
de l'esprit de noël
quoique en ces temps troublés autant ne
pas faire l'économie d'une bonne action